it says a certain tank has an inlet
valve and an outlet valve the tank can
be filled via the inlet valve in six
minutes and emptied from full via the
outlet valve in ten minutes
if both valves are operating how long
would it take to fill the tank
it was empty to begin with now what's
great about this question is that like
this is just it's in an exercise about
linear equations for pizza you know how
are you meant to be able to solve this
but it's taken away all the cues that
you used to have like you know when you
see something like this you can do this
on autopilot right all the cues are
there you'd know what to do you just
rearrange things that you do it quite
mindlessly this question is the exact
opposite of that there are no pluses or
minuses there's a couple of numbers sure
but they defy the normal ways in your
process ok so here's what I'm going to
do general problem solving strategy that
you must have access to when a problem
confuses you put it either in simpler
terms or more concrete terms so that you
can solve it right so one of the
problems with this is that you don't
know how big the tank is you don't know
how big the take is you don't need to
know how big the take is but that
confuses you so let me give you an
example of how big the tech is and
you'll see how simple this question is
right here he's my tank I've got a I've
got water coming in and I've got water
going out
okay so you think about what would be a
nice number that would make it easy to
work out weren't easy to work with the
numbers that we've been given and I'm
gonna choose 60 litres 60 litres is a
nice neat number because it says six
minutes to fill the tank
six minutes to fill the tank so if it's
a sixty liter tank how many liters are
going in every minute ten liters okay so
this is this is easy to wrap our heads
around ten liters are going in every
minute okay conversely ten minutes for
it to empty so how much is coming out
ten minutes hold on ten minutes 60 litre
take six liters are coming up every
minute yes okay no it's empty right now
and I turn on the hose turn on the towel
every minute ends going in six is coming
up so what's the net result every minute
four liters are gonna stay in the tank
right and then the next minute I'll get
another four and then another and so on
okay so four liters per minute and
there's a sixty litre tank right so
there for 15 minutes now stops okay all
right now this this approach is kind of
okay if it landed on the right answer
didn't do okay however that doesn't
address the fact that it was a sixty
later tape they didn't tell us right so
therefore since I don't know what the
actual volume is I don't know that it's
gonna be ten liters going in and six
liters coming out but now it's thick I
can i here's where the promise on which
i think it comes in if you didn't know
is sixty right but it is we take it that
it's you know not a shape-shifting sort
of tank right so it's gonna be some kind
of volume let's call it X liters
okay so stays put now where do I get
those numbers before how did I come up
with ten how did we come up with ten
you said we took it's going to take six
minutes right to fill up yeah
so therefore this should be X divided by
six which one which gave us ten before
right that's how much is going in with
whatever six is whatever X is rather how
much is coming out well we had six
letters here and we got back from X on
ten okay so now we say well I don't know
the exact number of leaders that are
going in there right but it should be
excellent six take away what's being
removed at the same time okay
XO six ten what's that equal to well you
do you do some common common factors
here thirty thirty will do so this is 5x
on 30 and that's three next on 30 liters
per minute right do my fractions right
so that's 2x on 30 liters per minute so
I just simplify now that's the actual
rate how much do I want I want it to be
full right how many liters are there
when it's full X liters if it's going on
X or 15 liters per minute and I want to
get 2x it's gonna take me 15 of those so
just what did I do
the 15 of you did not do okay I did two
things number one I simplified it down
right sometimes the problem can be too
complicated and need to remove things
that are making a confusing secondly I
made it more concrete you did it nerve
so I just said well suppose and it's not
that hard then you take that principle
and you generalize that make sense